ukrainians keep a weary eye on U.S
midterm elections fearing a loss of
support and I say good because I watched
uh something on Reddit I didn't want to
watch it I was scrolling Reddit all and
within one or two pages I came across a
video and I didn't read the caption I
just saw the video and it was a guy in
military gear curled up in the fetal
position in a foxhole
and then I'm like what's what's this and
then all of a sudden a grenade just
falls from the overhead view oh it was a
drone carrying a grenade the grenade
lands in the hole and then you see it go
off and the body gets shocked and then
this Soldier start writhing and crawling
and struggling to move like an ant under
a magnifying glass and then the video
jumps again this time there's three
people in a foxhole and then you see a
grenade fall right down land right next
someone's side and then boom Flash the
body's jostle
then you see a man get up writhing in
agony and covered in blood shaking
profusely and I got really angry and I
really want to just throw my phone at
the wall why did Reddit put that in
front of my face am I supposed to
celebrate that the evil Russian Invaders
were being blown up in front of me that
when I go to a social media website with
no not safer work tags that's what you
want me to watch
the people who are advocating for the US
to be involved in this are psychopaths I
don't like Russia for invading and I'm
not going to cheer for someone being
blown up but this is what we're seeing
so if the midterms mean we cut ties and
we end support for a war we shouldn't be
involved in at this point
good I'm sick of this disgusting garbage
it's these stupid people on the left
blindly marching behind War yeah I just
watched they shall not grow old last
night it's a Peter Jackson documentary
basically we took Old World War One
footage black and white footage and
colorized it and added sound and you see
these young 18 17 16 year olds that
signed up for the war are so excited the
Brotherhood being together working for a
common purpose and then they get to the
that you see watch them March to the
[ __ ] trench and then they're in the
trenches where people it's mud they're
falling they're freezing their feet are
getting Frozen off then they tell them
to go up over the top and charge the
machine gun nests they it's the first
time they've ever seen machine guns they
don't even know what they are so they
start walking they're not even running
they're walking but there's no machine
guns they're like what's going on maybe
they're Germans aren't ready the Germans
are waiting for them to get into range
and then they open up and they see their
friends the British these they're
getting arms blown off legs getting
blown off dudes getting their heads
exploded and they're laying
they get hit they keep this is the this
isn't they didn't know Modern War they
didn't understand modern military
technology now foxholes are no good
anymore because drones can drop a
grenade in them this is this is this is
always War they no they never
underestimate the new tactics and
strategies sorry you were gonna say no
so one of my my first job when I was 15
years old working at a hardware store
there's an old guy that worked there and
come to find out he was on Iwo Jima and
he never spoke about his War experiences
or anything like that people would ask
him stuff and he essentially blow it off
and he'd be gone and I will never I was
15 years old so it's been a long time
now and for some reason just one day he
opened up and he just he just grabbed
landing on the beach and running over
the body's parts and it wasn't bodies it
was body parts of his friends and it's
like he he just like clicked and it's
this moment it was like for a minute or
two he just described it and he kept
talking about the smell
and it was just incredible to see
someone say that and relive that in his
mind his name was Jack Walken it's a
true American hero but to hear that from
him like it's left an impact on me to
this day it's been a long time the smell
the smell of explosion no well not at
first you don't smell it but then they
start to Decay and then yeah they were
there for quite a few days or weeks
that's the smell it's also an energy
there's also a lot of other things
happening when when it comes to human
beings and the Soul leaving the physical
body scientists haven't been able to
explain it but there's a phenomenon that
does happen that is absolutely
um I I you know Indescribable in many
instances but we also have to understand
war is hell this is Hell on Earth this
is what a lot of people you know are in
this is what the mainstream media is
cheering for this is what politicians
are financing and funding with your
money right now and it's absolutely
egregious and it's absolutely stupid I
watch you know a lot of the footage
coming from the Russians coming from the
ukrainians to try to get a fair balanced
perspective about what's really going on
in this conflict and it's predominantly
drone on drone Warfare drones blowing up
drones drones flying With Grenades
drones reconing getting positions and
then having of course missiles strike
those specific positions where soldios
are at and very few instances have I've
seen soldiers to soldiers actually fight
each other it's all done through robots
it's all done through machines
um and and seeing this new Modern
Warfare which was which we were
conditioned to through the video games
which also have you flying drones and
flying all these carts and sending in
airstrikes uh is is absolutely
terrifying because you see the horror
you see the chaos and it's not up close
it's not face to face like it was in
World War one it's far away and people
are just pressing imagine killing and
eliminating each other imagine that
you're uh 20 years old
and hey gen Z I want you to Imagine This
and your government calls you to war
they say we have no choice we are at war
with a great enemy and you must go fight
so you resist
and then one day when you're sneaking
out of your friend's basement because
you don't want to fight
a couple of uh cops see you chase you
down grab you and you get shipped off to
the front line you're at the front line
in Ukraine put the helmet on put on the
gear you have no time for training This
Is War
so you're pushed out into a middle of
the field and you're hiding in a hole
crying saying why am I here when a
grenade lands on you and blows up
that's what's happening to these people
many of these people fighting for Russia
are conscripts I'm not saying what
Russia is doing is good obviously I'm
saying it's bad
but to watch videos of these people and
then we're supposed to cheer on this
psychotic propaganda how about this the
U.S should not be involved in this NATO
should not be involved in this NATO
should take care of itself Ukraine is
not a NATO member not an EU member state
they're trying to be but only after the
war started and we should say you know
what we shouldn't be involved in a
border dispute with a nuclear-armed
state and then we wouldn't have to deal
with this psycho The Psychotic garbage
yeah you know and and again what we're
seeing though that Drone footage is just
one of of dozens of videos that come
come out every single day and it's not
just the Russians being hit it's also
the ukrainians being hit it's also
Russians sending in missiles into
civilian areas hitting buildings where
people are just trying to live their
lives this war hits both ways and this
is the this is how all war plays out
every time there's a war both sides
figure something out hey they did this
thing technology advances tactics I'm
sorry technology advances tactics
advance and then when the new war breaks
out like Ian was mentioning they're in
the trenches saying charge and also
sudden there's machine guns mowing them
down because tactics change slower than
the technology technology changes so I
actually have a civil war bullet it's a
gardener bullet I think it's 58 caliber
and uh it's a fascinating I gotta I
gotta the the the
um Stonewall Museum
and uh it's got some interesting facts
on it it said that for the most part
muskets were smoothbore very inaccurate
effective only up to about a hundred
yards I believe it was 100 yards
smoothbore so you'd point it in Fire and
it'd go wildly in the wrong direction at
some point uh up right before some point
before the Civil War we get rifle rifled
muskets so now for those who don't know
rifling and the reason why they're
called rifles is because the inside of
the barrel has a small spiral Groove so
when the bullet is fired it spins
dramatically increasing accuracy
tripling or quadrupling the range of
your standard musket when the Civil War
broke out neither side truly understood
what that meant and used conventional
War tactics like bayonet charges and
then with a maximized accuracy we saw
one of the bloodiest Wars we've ever
seen this is what happens when new war
breaks out with technological
advancement now that we have a massive
global population and technology is
advancing quite dramatically it's not
going to be nuclear war you should be
fearing it should be the top secret
classified Weaponry they haven't told
you about which is going to be even more
nightmarish it'll be hacked drones uh
flown over civilian targets like your
family if that's what you're uh what
modern warfare Call of Duty doesn't show
you is the Drone getting hacked and
getting flown over Los Angeles yeah you
could hack drones in Modern Warfare yeah
there's also hives like small little
drones that are also in developed
already that could launch attacks on
individuals and and have little
explosives on them and have bullets on
them the technology that they have right
now is absolutely insane and and we
don't know much about bro listen
the a small a small drone probably about
this big can carry a Shotgun shell a 12
gauge or whatever and it can be
um with a what is it called Luca flash
it flat
is that what it called
not a slug uh spread razor blades oh
sharp pieces of metal I think those are
shots fleshette and so that little tiny
drone can fly up to you and you go
what's that and then it bang and sprays
metal shards all over the place blinding
and and scarring people yeah amazing oh
it's just insane the level technology
it's not going to be fun but I'll tell
you man
one thing they don't show you in Call of
Duty is the 20 year old crying because
he was conscripted by his government to
fight in a war and he doesn't want to be
there and then well then his officer is
like if you turn around I'm going to
shoot you go go over the edge yep
literally uh and they also don't show
you your friends getting wounded and
screaming and paying for 20 minutes or
for four hours wait you know because he
can't get to them there's going to be a
handful of gen's ears because they lean
very heavily Democrat there's going to
be two let me tell you a story of two
Jen's let's say let's say they're 22
years old
one's a staunch Democrat who loves
watching H3 and agrees with Ethan Klein
about Ben Shapiro and all that other
nonsense watches Hassan [ __ ] and so
he's like you know what we got to stop
Russia we gotta we gotta stop him so
they say I'm gonna vote Democrat not let
the Republicans are that much better but
at the very least with Trump he opposes
this stuff well that person has a friend
the friend doesn't know doesn't care and
doesn't pay attention but lo and behold
the war escalates NATO gets involved and
the U.S says we have not been able to
replenish our forces to to a degree
where we could actually fight and win so
we're going to reenact the draft
these 22 year olds let's say it's in a
few years so they're 18 today they both
find themselves on the front lines and
one is saying why is the the the one
friend friend B who uh doesn't never
paid attention to this doesn't care is
saying I wish I paid attention and could
have done something about this and the
other friend says well actually I kind
of voted for it and then the bomb goes
off and they both explode you know I was
thinking where are our strong men
sociologically in the world right now
what happened why are people so latching
onto Donald Trump and Jordan Peterson
why do they need a father figure if you
know what put it put attack in that
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive Library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there